there are many challenges and the
structures in the world presently are
such that vital issues relating to
security are not transparent decisions
are taking with old people involvement
so more democracy and I don't mean only
voting but more possibilities for people
to influence policies is a challenge
that we hope to overcome this unfinished
democracy which are all over the world
have to be more transparent it's also
difficult for people sometimes to know
who has the power is it the
multinationals is it the big powers the
government's and it is a very strange
thing that those countries that have
nuclear weapons tend to think that they
are the big powers they should be shamed
how come that they can go and be proud
of having something that can annihilate
the word and of course the environmental
issues are extremely important so for
IPP we look at peace in relation to
security for the world it's not only
national security it is human security
and it is environmental security so we
have many challenges but we believe in
the young people to help see the bigger
picture and meet these challenges and
with the new social media particularly
young people but all of us are able to
communicate and share knowledge in a way
that we haven't seen before so the
challenge is also their manager
it's difficult to get funding for peace
activities these days how do we do it
should be linked more closely with the
development organizations that tend to
have money with the environmental
organizations that human rights
organizations I think we need to do that
there is one other challenge which is
the rhetoric because there is a lot of
talk about peace but in a way that is
very hollow it's fake they don't believe
in it so for people to know when it is
the hollow and fake peace talk in front
of them and when it is the real thing
it's not particularly obvious so we have
to analyze how media is very often
unfortunately by being unconscious about
this or doing it deliberately I don't
know driving world opinion in favor of
military solutions to conflicts instead
of nonviolent dialogue and solutions for
instance we have heard over the last I
would say almost year and a half that oh
there is no solution in Syria and they
don't mean that there is no solution but
they say they mean there is no military
solution because the Security Council is
not agreeing so many challenges and we
have to be optimistic as to being able
to to change this otherwise we would
just stay on the coach all of us and not
do anything so challenges are there to
be met